para todas las moléculas cíclicas con
las que hemos trabajado sólo los hemos
dibujado como anillos por ejemplo para
el ciclo hexano vamos a ver cuando
dibujamos el ciclo hexano literalmente
sólo dibuja vamos un hexágono verdad
déjenme ponerle un poquito mejor ahí
tienen ustedes
un hexágono al menos más o menos este es
un hexágono ok y así es como siempre
hemos estado representando el ciclo
exacto verdad justo como un hexágono
ahora sabemos de los últimos vídeos que
todos los enlaces del carbono no siempre
se encuentran sobre el mismo plano por
ejemplo si tomamos el ejemplo del metano
verdad tenemos nuestro carbono digamos
en el centro de esta molécula y tenemos
dos átomos de hidrógeno que se
encuentran en el mismo plano pero un
átomo de hidrógeno sale un poco más allá
digamos de este plano de esta hoja donde
lo estamos pintando y otro se queda un
poco vapor atrás de la hoja verdad
entonces está esta configuración del
metano además sabemos que entre estos
dos hidrógenos o de hecho entre
cualesquiera dos tenemos ciento 9.5
grados aproximadamente y por supuesto no
siempre hay un ángulo de 109.5 entre
cualesquiera dos hidrógenos de cualquier
molécula verdad depende de qué con que
otros átomos estemos relacionando este
carbono con cuál es este
uniendo así que con esto que hemos
estado viendo cómo podríamos visualizar
una molécula de ciclohexano justamente
en tres dimensiones así que para pensar
en ello vamos a pensar primero en estos
dos enlaces déjenme déjenme pintarlos
vamos a pensar en estos dos enlaces ok
ok
entonces esos dos enlaces los voy a
poner digamos de esta forma y tenemos
uno y acá tenemos
otro ok
ahora este digamos que estoy pintando
como con magenta vamos a ponerlo algo
así más o menos vamos a poner este rosa
que ahí tienen este rosa lo pintamos acá
de este lado de esa forma y estos
morados este morado y este otro morado
voy a pintarlos más o menos así muy bien
entonces esta esta forma de dibujar el
ciclo hexano es justamente lo que se
conoce como la conformación si ya verdad
y justamente ya puedes ver más o menos
por qué se le dice si ya este digamos
sería como el respaldo en esta parte
sería justamente donde donde te sientas
en la silla y estos serían como como las
patas delanteras verdad
ahora otra otra configuración posible
que podemos hacer para este ciclo hexano
es la configuración de bote aunque vote
en el sentido por ejemplo de barco y eso
más o menos se vería de esta forma de
estos dos enlaces azules pues serían
digamos algo así
más o menos el este enlace magenta iría
así muy bien este enlace rosa iría más o
menos así y los enlaces morados pues los
podremos poner algo así muy bien y más o
menos esta es la figura de un bote
verdad de un barco nos podríamos
pintarle que una bandera o que se yo
ahora la primera cosa que lo mejor te
estás preguntando porque a lo mejor
estás diciendo es es que yo había dicho
que la razón por la cual estos carbonos
tienden a formar digamos figuras de
tetraedro o estas figuras de trípode de
triples perdón en realidad a lo mejor
podríamos estar pensando que no ves esas
figuras de tripié en ninguna de estas
dos configuraciones ok entonces lo que
está pasando es que en realidad falta
dibujar los hidrógenos verdad tenemos
que dibujar los hidrógenos para poder
ver esas estructuras entonces por
ejemplo aquí podríamos poner nuestro
hidrógeno que va hacia arriba ok vamos a
poner este otro hidrógeno que va hacia
arriba
este otro que va hacia abajo
este otro también irá hacia abajo
vamos a poner este que también va hacia
arriba y este que va hacia abajo verdad
y más o menos ya uno empieza a ver cómo
se empiezan a formar las estructuras de
tripp y de verdad aquí vamos a poner
también esta estructura este este
hidrógeno vamos a poner este cuál será
cuál será
quizás debería dibujar un poco mejor
este hidrógeno antes
no
ok vamos a poner este hidrógeno más o
menos así ok
ya verán por qué estoy pintando los de
esta forma este también se verá como
algo así ok aquí tenemos que poner otro
hidrógeno vamos a ponerlo de esta forma
aquí nos falta otro vamos a ponerlo de
esta otra forma ok y finalmente estos
dos verdad vamos a ponerlo aquí y vamos
a ponerlo acá muy bien entonces ahí
tienen más o menos en cada uno de estos
carbonos ustedes pueden ver como como la
figura de tetraedro verdad o la figura
de tripié más o menos para eso es que
nos sirven estas configuraciones silla y
bote y bueno en unos momentos vamos a
ver qué pasa con el bote y ahora que ya
hemos dibujado los hidrógenos que están
saliendo se digamos
bueno los que hemos puesto con color
amarillo que son los que van hacia
arriba o hacia abajo verdad de hecho lo
hemos hecho así por un propósito en
particular estos que van hacia arriba o
hacia abajo estos de aquí que son los
amarillos son los que como se les conoce
como hidrógenos axiales muy bien estos
son los hidrógenos axiales y justamente
sólo son porque van hacia arriba o hacia
abajo ahora bien si éstos tienen un
nombre los rojos también tienen un
nombre y estos son los hidrógenos
ecuatoriales los hidrógenos ecuatoriales
ahora bien porque se les dice hidrógenos
ecuatoriales pues fíjense muy bien en lo
siguiente este hidrógeno que intente
pintar de esta forma este de aquí en
realidad se les dice ecuatoriales porque
son los enlaces los pintamos de forma
paralela a alguna otra parte del de esta
misma molécula entonces por ejemplo éste
es paralelo a esta otra de acá vamos a
tratar de ver todos los que son
paralelos sale entonces por ejemplo este
de aquí este de aquí es paralelo a este
enlace de aquí vamos a ver qué otro por
ejemplo y no se esté de aquí es paralelo
a este de aquí sale que otro podríamos
ver ahora vamos a poner otro color se me
están acabando los colores
por ejemplo
este de aquí
este justo este de aquí que estoy
pintando con café es paralelo a este
otro de aquí verdad y ya tenemos los 123
falta 1 verdad por ejemplo este de aquí
vamos a ponerlo con blanco este de aquí
a quien sería paralelo
quizás aquí no lo pinte muy bien déjenme
pintarlo mejor creo que sí estaba bien
como en el otro caso pero justamente
para que éste sea paralelo pues tiene
que ser paralelo a este verdad entonces
aquí tendremos nuestro hidrógeno y este
enlace de aquí sería paralelo a este de
acá entonces esta es la razón por la
cual les llamamos hidrógenos ecuatorial
perdón hidrógenos ecuatoriales vamos a
ver como dibujar los hidrógenos en el
caso de la conformación bote aquí
tenemos un hidrógeno que va hacia arriba
que es justamente el axial por ejemplo
aquí podemos poner uno que va hacia
abajo también es axial éste también irá
hacia abajo axial éste irá hacia arriba
ok por ejemplo aquí podremos ponerlo
hacia abajo y aquí también verdad
entonces falta dibujar los que van a ser
los ecuatoriales por ejemplo este de
aquí
estoy aquí podría ser ecuatorial y es
paralelo a este este de acá por ejemplo
vamos a hacerlo de esta forma así y es
paralelo a este este sería también
paralelo por ejemplo a este o déjenme
ver
no quizás los estoy poniendo mal verdad
en realidad este de aquí si este es
paralelo a este este tendría que ser
paralelo a este verdad entonces sería
como algo así este de aquí tendría que
ser paralelo a este lado y este día acá
tendría que ser paralelo verdad muy bien
entonces y bueno así podríamos seguir
con con el resto de los hidrógenos
verdad entonces el detalle de aquí es
que aún no sabemos por qué son tan
distintos estas dos con formaciones y
justamente en la línea que sellamos en
el vídeo anterior uno puede preguntarse
bueno cuál de estos dos es más estable
entonces vamos a fijarnos por ejemplo en
este se h dos en este aquí y aquí
tenemos un carbono y tenemos estos dos
hidrógenos si nos fijamos en éste sh2 y
en este otro de aquí tenemos este
carbono y estos dos hidrógenos podemos
notar que la distancia que hay entre
estos dos es mucho mayor que por ejemplo
si nos fijamos en estos dos
estos 12 h 2 corresponden a estos dos en
la conformación bote perdón y si nos
damos cuenta en este caso están a una
mayor distancia y como ya sabemos pues
hay muchísimas no hay hay nubes de
electrones alrededor de cada uno de
estos átomos si pensamos a éste como un
grupo completo pues podremos ver que
como están a una mayor distancia la
repulsión es menor verdad entonces
quiere decir que está esta conformación
es más estable en cambio si consideramos
la conformación bote por ejemplo estos
dos se encuentran más cerca que en la
conformación silla quiere decir que
estos dos van a tratar de repeler se y
cambiar la conformación así que esta es
la menos estable esta es la conformación
menos estable así que este es digamos el
punto de partida de cómo visualizar
hidrocarburos cíclicos y vamos a
utilizar esta información en el próximo
vídeo para pensar un poquito más acerca
de las diferentes configuraciones sí ya
que una molécula puede tener ok que son
justo de las más estables en esta
situación en el caso del ciclo hexano
las dos configuraciones sillas son
reales son igualmente estables y déjenme
dibujar las dos configuraciones y ya que
podemos tener por ejemplo
podremos tener justamente esta que ya
hemos pintado déjenme volverla a poner
tenemos esta de aquí
algo así más o menos ok
déjenme ponerlo con con los mismos
colores digamos que vamos a poner este
con rosa y este también con rosa y el
último vamos a ponerlo con magenta
verdad
ok entonces tenemos aquí una de las
configuraciones
silla y la otra es más o menos al revés
como como volteado
ok algo así tenemos
esta rosa
esta rosa también y finalmente los
magenta aunque ni entonces estas dos son
distintas configuraciones si ya que
esencialmente son igualmente estables de
ponerlo así digamos que en ese sentido
son es una cuestión de equilibrio son
esto son igualmente estables ahora cuál
es la gran diferencia entre estas dos
configuraciones si pensamos por ejemplo
en los hidrógenos axiales déjenme
déjenme poner aquí un hidrógeno axial y
un hidrógeno axial aquí y por lo tanto
tendremos nuestro hidrógeno
ecuatorial de genueve corresponde a algo
así algo así
y aquí el ecuatorial entonces lo que va
a ocurrir con estos dos es que una vez
que tenemos un hidrógeno axial va a
pasar a ser un hidrógeno ecuatorial
cuando cambiamos a la otra configuración
silla por ejemplo este amarillo este
amarillo de aquí arriba ahora pasaría a
ser un hidrógeno ecuatorial que sería
paralelo a este lado y el rosa que
tenemos aquí sería un hidrógeno axial
muy bien por ejemplo en el otro caso
pues tendríamos aquí este hidrógeno que
antes ser axial y ahora es ecuatorial y
el ecuatorial ahora pasa a ser axial y
lo mismo podemos hacer con el resto de
los hidrógenos por ejemplo vamos a
hacerlo vamos a hacerlo aquí tenemos
este hidrógeno axial este otro hidrógeno
axial este otro hidrógeno axial y este
otro hidrógeno axial ok por ejemplo el
hidrógeno
ecuatorial sería paralelo a este verdad
en este caso sería paralelo a este lo
tienen yo sé que a veces es un poco
difícil difícil de verlo pero bueno
vamos a quedarnos sólo con esos dos para
no entretenernos más y por ejemplo éste
pasaría a ser cual pasaría a ser este de
aquí digamos ok entonces aquí tendremos
este axial sería ahora ecuatorial y
sería paralelo a este lado a este lado y
ahí lo tienen y el otro pasaría a ser
axial verdad entonces tenemos algo así y
en el otro caso pues tendríamos que este
axial sería ahora paralelo a este otro
lado verdad y el rosa pasaría a hacer
en rosa que era ecuatorial ahora es
axiales pero allí ha dicho todo esto muy
bien realmente si te das cuenta todo
esto es pura práctica de cómo visualizar
estas moléculas en tres dimensiones